[Applause]  the shot of the night  to this point is roach answers back with  a quick two  you want to pound right away remember  duke's out of time he's got ready  how about that shot  this one  again no timeouts  oh they wave off the basket we're going  to say early  i think it's the right call  hadn't started that motion  smart awareness didn't have the three  attack off the bounce drive and  i think  [Applause]  that was the right call yeah gene yeah  no question this is this is just after  the dribble's picked up the ball hasn't  started up at all this is on the floor  we're shooting two though man right  we're in a two-shot scenario here but  not a shooting foul no and one